[音楽]
[拍手]
私が
心とは何か心は体とその周りの環境とどの
ような関係にあるのかということについて
お話をします
といってもすごく大きなテーマであまり
ピンと来ないかもしれないので
具体的なところから話を始めたいと思い
ます今日のテーマが
根気強く努力することってことなので
根気強く努力するための意志基本について
考えてみると
皆さん一度は私は医師が弱いなというふう
に思ったことがあるかと思います
健康に気をつけようと思ったのに次
ドーナツを食べちゃうであったり
プレゼンの準備をしようと思ったのに
YouTubeを見てしまうみたいなこと
はみんなあるのかなというふうに思います
みんなありますよね
でこういう例を考えると心と体心と環境と
いうのは対立しているように思われるかも
しれません
つまり一方で私たちは心を持ってして体を
コントロールしようとしているけれども心
と環境がそれを邪魔してくるっていうよう
な関係です
古代
ギリシャの哲学者
プラトンは
肉体は魂を惑わすものだというふうに言い
ましたが今のような例を考えるとそれも
不思議ではないかもしれません
魂っていうのは今ではあんまり使わない
言葉ですがこのように心と体っていうのを
切り離して理解するのは実は現代でも
あんまり珍しいことではありません
近年人工知能の発達が目覚ましく
いずれコンピューターを人間のような心を
持つんじゃないかということが言われる
ことがありますが
よく考えるとこのような考え方の背後には
人間の心の方が一種のコンピューター
プログラムなんだというような考え方が
書かれていますだからこそコンピューター
にも心が宿るかもしれないというふうに
思われるわけですね
私たちは日常的に例えば何か環境の物事を
解釈してそこから結論を出すことを頭の中
で計算するなんていう風に言う時があり
ますがその言葉通りに人間の心っていうの
は
脳の中に
脳というハードウェアに搭載された
医師のソフトウェアなんだというわけです
ね
でこの時体の方に目を向けるとこの目とか
耳とかの感覚器官というのはこの頭の中の
システムに感覚信号を送るようなデバイス
いわばラップトップのwelcomeだっ
たりマイクみたいなものででも腕とか足
みたいな運動期間っていうのはこの頭の中
のシステムかも指令を実行するデバイス
なんかロボットアームだったりあるいは
プリンターだったりそんなようなものと
いう風に考えられていることになります
でこれは一見すると心を魂として考えると
いうのは全然違う考え方なんですが実は
そこに一つ共通点があります何かって言う
と心が生きた体とは本質的につながりを
持たないものというふうに考えていきたい
ん
ですけれども心を一種のソフトウェアだっ
ていう風に考えるということは人間の心は
たまたまこの生きた体に
搭載されているもの
原理的にはできたからじゃ体じゃなくても
いいもの例えば人工的なコンピューターの
上でも成立するものそして考えていること
になるからです
しかし最近の哲学や
認知科学の領域では
心と体そして心と
環境っていうのはもっと密接につながっ
てるんじゃないかという風に考えている
動きがありますその動きの中では
身体的な心
[音楽]
環境に埋め込まれた心
環境に広がる心
エネクティブな心
生態学的エコロジカルな心
ティオナ様々な言葉のもとで様々な考え方
が
提案されています
もうちょっと具体的にしかし心がこの身体
や
環境と密接につながっているというのが
どういうことなのかを見ていきたいと思い
ますはじめに心と生命のつながりという
ものについて考えていきましょう
コンピューターはもちろん生き物じゃあり
ませんなので心をコンピューター
プログラムだという風に考えるということ
は心と生命の間に本質的なつながりはない
というふうに考えることになります
しかし本当にそうなんでしょうか
生き物っていうのは何かというと
環境とのインタラクションを通じて自ら
自らを存続させるような存在です
例えばコンピューターの電源を
抜いて1ヶ月そのまま置いておくと1か月
後にもう1回電源を入れたら大抵の場合も
1回使い始めることができますよね
でも生き物に食料や水を与えるのをやめて
で1か月
1か月後に食料に与えても大変な生き物は
また動き始めるということはないですよね
つまり生き物は環境とインタラクションし
続けていないと死んでしまうわけです
生き物の中でも最も原始的なものの一つと
して大腸菌っていうものを考えてみると
大腸菌はここに体も膜があってこの膜を
通じて
環境内の例えばスクロースを摂取します
そうですねそれを摂取してこのMacの中
の代謝のネットワークを使ってそれを
エネルギーに変えます
そのエネルギーを使って新陳代謝を進め
たりこの専門を動かして
環境の中を移動したりします
こういうことができなくなると死んで
しまうわけですね
ここで注目したいのがこのような生命活動
があると
環境の中に意味が生じるということです
クローズスクロース分子っていうのはそれ
自体としては単なる化学物質なのですが
大腸菌はスクロースを代謝してエネルギー
に変えられるそういう体を持っている
おかげでスクロース分子とその他の分子に
対して
異なって仕方で関わりますちょっと人間
っぽい言葉を使ってしまうと大腸菌は
スクロースを食べ物あるいは栄養として
扱うわけですね
私たち人間は日頃から
環境の物事の意味や価値を解釈するって
ことを行っていますが実は大腸菌には
すごく原始的な生命においてもそれに似た
ようなことが起きているわけですね
そうすると生命と心の間には本質的な
つながりがないどころか実は生き
るっていうのはそれ自体が
環境の意味を解釈するっていう心の働きの
ちっちゃな芽生えみたいなものがもう
すでに含まれているということになります
このような考え方は近年の研究では生命と
心の連続性
スタートして呼ばれています
でこの生命の
身体的な生命活動と
環境人数に心の働きのつながりというのは
大腸菌だけじゃなくてバクテリアだけじゃ
なくてもっと複雑な体を持った生き物でも
確認できますこのような考え方は生態学的
心理学エコロジカルサイコロジーという
分野で特に発達してきまし
サイコロジーの分野では動物は
アフォーダンスというものの観点から
環境を経験するんだというふうにアポー
ダンスって何かというと
環境が提供する行動の機会のことを意味し
ます
例えばこのようにこの辺を見ていただくと
硬くて
平らで水平な表面があると私たちはその上
を歩くことができますよねなのでこのよう
な表面見ると私たちこう歩ける場所そして
認知しますそこに歩くことパフォーマンス
を見てときます
でこのように
硬くて
垂直で高い表面があると私たちはそこを
通り抜けることができないのでそこに今度
はこっちには止まることのアポを出すを見
ておりますあるいはこの車乗ってるみたい
にすごい早く移動しているとそこに衝突
することのパフォーマンスを聞いて
[音楽]
おりますパフォーマンスというのは
環境にあるだけじゃなくて動物の身体能力
と
環境の物質的特性の関係によって決まり
ますなのでなんか弾劾絶壁を登ることが
できるようなそういう体を持った
アイベックスのような動物であったらこの
硬い高い表面はそういう動物には
登ることをサポートすることになります
っていうのは
私たちに対して行動を誘導する効果もあり
ます
例えば今歩き疲れた時にこういう電池が出
てきたとしてちょっと皆さんここに
座りますかそれとも寝転がりますか
皆さんの体の大きさにもよると思うんです
がこの電池は大抵の方におのずと座ること
を
誘導する僕は思ってます
なぜかというとここに仕切りがついてるの
で寝っころ見にくいんですねなので
おのずと寝っころがるというのが選択肢に
上がりにくくなっているわけですね
でこのような例を考えると実は人間って
いうのは頭の中で行動の計画を作ってそれ
に基づいて体を動かしているというわけで
は必ずしもなくて実はこうやって環境の力
を借りながら行動を形成する存在であると
いうことが見えてきます
このようなパフォーマンスの理論は
環境を認識する心っていうのがどんな体
どんなものにもインストールできるような
ソフトウェアではなくて
実は
私たちの体そのものともっと密接に
つながってもらうということを示唆してい
ます
動物がアフォーダンスを経験する仕方って
いうのは動物がどのような体を持っている
かということと密接につながってきます
なので体っていうのは例えばこの目や耳を
通じて頭の中に感覚信号を送るだけの
デバイスだということを考えることができ
ません
むしろ私たちの心はこの身体そのものに
よって作られているんだということが
示唆
パフォーマンスというのはまた環境から
一方的に与えられるだけのものでもあり
ません
今この場には様々なパフォーマンスがあり
ますがそのほとんどが
あるいは全部かもしれません人間が作った
人工的なもの
です動物はこのように環境に
介入してそこに様々なアフォーマンスを
含む場を作るということをやりますこの
働きは
ニッチ構築っていうふうに呼ばれますこの
ニッチ構築と人間の心の間にも深い
つながりがあります
認知工事の中には
認知的
認知構築っていう風に呼ばれるタイプの
ものがありますこれは何かというと人間の
認知能力考える力に関わるようなフォー
ダンスを含むそういう場所を作るそういう
働きのことを言います
考えるって言うと私たちが頭の中でやる
ことの代表格のように思われるかもしれ
ません
できるとよく考えてみると実は私たちは
認知的な作業をこの時にしょっちゅう道具
を使います
例えばこの例だとこの人は
チョークと黒板を使って数学の問題を解い
てます
現在であればスマホを使うとか
コンピューターを使うとかテクノロジーを
使うことも多いでしょう
さらに僕でも根本的なレベルで言うと
私たちは言語を使ったり数字を使ったりし
て思考します
また他者とのコミュニケーションだったり
他者とのインタラクションを通じて考える
ということもよくあります
つまり実は考えるということももっぱら
この頭の中で起きていることではなくて
私たちが体を使って
環境とインタラクションする中で行う活動
なんですね
人類は長い時間をかけてこの社会的で文化
的な人工物があふれた環境を作ってきまし
たがこう考えると実はそれは人類が長い
時間をかけて自分たちの心を発達させてき
たそういう歴史なんだというふうに考える
こともできるわけ
このような形で私たちの心は体を持ってい
て
環境に広がっているわけ
ですそこで初めの話に戻るんですがこう
いう風に考えると皆さんの意志が弱いのは
もしかしたら皆さん一人一人の問題では
ないのかもしれませ
ん
むしろ強い意志を持つために必要なのは
なんとかこの狭い頭の中からなんとか
精神力を絞り出すということではなくて
体や環境の在り方やったり体や環境との
付き合い方を見直すことにあるのかもしれ
ません
以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]